[Music]
whoopee I have to ask you you felt the
need to respond to roseanne when she
retweeted a shirt of yours that was
doctored why did you feel the need to
have to speak out on that well because
this frickin shirt comes up every time
somebody wants to say something and I
just feel like you have to just keep
saying it's not real you know I
understand you you're going through you
but don't take me with you don't try to
take I didn't I can get bad in my own
you know if they make up stuff about me
anyway but so I just wanted to be clear
can she come back
can she come back from this I'm sure she
can yeah everybody seems to be able to
come back so Miss Whoopi I love this I
really love this on you I did not design
it I know it looks like I might up but I
didn't Christian
okay Christians tell me what is the
inspiration and how did you know like
this is everything I'm just now I just
was going for it I've known like my fair
lady may be a pimp maybe whatever
I just want to Whoopi to like feel
amazing you know but also like I
literally said I was like what about a
fuchsia suit a fabulous hat really give
a cool moment she's never been in CFDA
Awards and you know you get you know
pants pockets you know make it just easy
and fun I don't think I've ever seen you
in this color it's gorgeous on you thank
you like I couldn't imagine bringing
anyone out tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]